>> Hi, this is Andrew and
Michael from Cognition Team.
This is a demo of the prototype
of Project Kinect for Azure,
and this is a
time-of-flight sensor
which going to be used in
a Project Kinect for Azure as
well as of the HoloLens
next generation.
So, what you're seeing right now
is sensor module in our task
case, task prototype case,
and it's connect to a PC,
and the PC will do
a local processing to convert
the raw image to the depth image
and there render it
into a 3D Point Cloud.
So, Michael is basically
the object right now
before the depth camera.
You can see the details of
his shirt is very clear,
and the stability of
deploying cards very good.
This camera has
a much better quality.
There are lots of increments
on the hardware and
software side, and you can see,
you can reach to
really close range as
well if you put your finger
near the camera,
and he's too got
a very good depth map.
Then, it has a very
wide field of view,
you can see I'm also in
the picture as well.
You may notice that
the range here,
I'm disappear because
this is a example mode,
which only showing
the short range.
But, we can switch to
a long-range as well,
and you can see is actually
is supporting much
further and also the Point Cloud
is really, really stable.
We are basically targeting
a high accurate depth camera
with low noise,
and also this is
very low power consumption
camera as well.
Eventually, this will be
our technology we are
going to use in HoloLens,
which is trying to help
people talking in the scenario
like 3D reconstruction,
or people tracking, and
also hand tracking gesture,
things like that.
Okay. That is about
this demo and if
your interesting
Project Kinect Azure,
please look for Project Kinect
for Azure keyword online.
We have a website that
have all the information,
you probably can viewing
a survey and bring your feedback,
and then keeping tune,
like we will be there. Thanks.